we're focused on financial misconduct by
jamie spears and we're going to uncover
all of the facts and see where they take
us getting to know brittany as you have
what do you just think about what
happened here about what was done to her
now that you've been working so closely
with her i've used the words in my court
filings kafkaesque nightmare
and i stand by that and from here what
do you see brittany doing we just saw
her post on instagram she's flying on a
plane and she said she's on cloud nine i
can't say where she is but she's in a
much nicer place than this and she is on
cloud nine she of course is engaged what
does she want to do once this
conservative ship ends because you
fought so ferociously already to make
that happen well that's a good question
and what i would say to that is for the
first time in about 13 years
that decision will be up to brittany and
only brittany and that's a great thing
what do you think about the fact that
all of this happened from the start i
know you weren't there in the beginning
but these incredible fans have fought
and said this was never right from the
start and britney finally found her
voice but it's been over a decade how
did the courts let this happen
that's not something for me to comment
on right now i have respect for the
courts judge penny has been nothing but
gracious and courteous to me that's not
what a lot of people want to hear but
that's the way i feel about judge penny
in terms of systemic issues nationally
this is something that the united states
congress is looking into right now i do
think conservatorship law is going to
change
today was a monumental day not only for
brittany but for justice and also in
terms of shining a light on
conservatorship law generally i think
out here we were surprised to hear that
samuel ingham was on today why was he on
and what could happen to him from here
he was her lawyer for 13 years and it
doesn't seem he fought the way you have
fought for her
i'm not going to comment on mr ingham he
can speak for himself what comments do
you have on the new york times
investigation in terms of possible
surveillance brittany i know you
mentioned it today in court
my comment on the new york times
investigation is i think it was
fantastic reporting
i think the information was specific
and credible
and i think there's going to be a lot
more reporting and a lot more
documentation
that comes out in that regard i will say
to the extent that jamie spears and
representatives
placed a listening device
under the bed of britney spears
and listened to
her communications and read her private
text messages including with her prior
lawyer
sam ingham it's one of the most
disgraceful
outrageous and unfathomable things i've
heard as a lawyer
what happens
what happens next with this and um will
ms spears have to go undergo some sort
of psychiatric evaluation perhaps mr
spears has conceded that no psychiatric
evaluation is necessary and what happens
next is the ultimate termination of this
conservatorship could the court ask we
just in terms of how conservatorship law
works could the court want an evaluation
to happen or is it for sure no
evaluation will happen to comment on the
specifics but i do think it's pointing
out that jamie spears himself in his
last court filing said not once or twice
but three times that no evaluation is
needed that was all in a desperate
effort really to avoid what happened
today
he desperately wanted to avoid being
suspended he wanted to terminate the
entire conservatorship in order to avoid
him being deposed under oath having to
answer for his misconduct and having to
turn over his files that's really what
today's effort
on their part was about and i'm proud to
say that they felt so many people
so many people have pointed out that
britney spears was in a conservatorship
and yet she worked she did tours she did
residencies and that that's so rare in a
conservatorship
again why do you think that happened and
what's the brittany that you know
because it seems like jamie spears tried
to keep her capacity in question for
many years he did and it's fair to look
at why and was there a financial
component to that was there a conflict
of interest i think the answers are yes
what has been the reaction going fine mr
rosenberg
i'm not going to comment on my
communications with my client but i
think you could assume she's very happy
will this wrap up by her 40th birthday
that's the goal
and do you think britney will want to
get married as soon as she can that's
something that only brittany can answer
you